jojo was geht und herzlich willkommen zu
meinem heutigen video ich muss gar nicht
viel dazu sagen jeder von euch den
wahrscheinlichen youtube trend letzter
zeit irgendwie extrem präsent ist dass
man in irgendeiner sache drin wartet da
gab es schon flut eller wackelpudding
chicken wings und alles mögliche
insgesamt ist das irgendwie ein bisschen
sinnbild dafür dass auf youtube relativ
viele schlechte videos zurzeit
produziert werden oder chronische videos
produziert werden hier wurde die letzten
stunden etwas vorbereitet und zwar werde
ich heute einen schlechten
youtube-videos baden kommt mit übrigens
leute ich sag mal so mein mcfit ring
ich sage also es hat sich nicht ist
nicht unbemerkt geblieben und ich habe
es schon ziemlich guten baden fackeln
nicht lange
petersburg gespannt wie es ist ist schon
länger ein traum von mir einfach mal den
ganzen badewanne folgen schlechten
youtube videos das wird vielleicht ein
bisschen eklig vielleicht ein bisschen
lustig man weiß es ja pläne deshalb
nehmen die ganzen youtuber dass ihr
aufsichtsrat heute allein du bist
görlich [ __ ] ja wobei ich den gewinn
ja ich hab mein körper funktioniert nur
hier sieht deshalb stehe ich mich alles
mit der ganzen welt zu zeigen oder ganz
youtube zu zeigen im internet
und ich würde sagen lassen wir meine
badewanne ein
so leute ich bin jetzt der badewanne und
ich bin schon richtig gespannt wie es
wird übrigens bald irgendwie in einen
kilo youtube videos sondern in 100 kilo
nur 15 minuten lang alles mit mir machen
welchen youtuber gehört dieser art ich
war schon ziemlich nass btw ich
befriedige mich mit einer burkl aber
lange es geht mir schon fast bis zum
hals
und wie ist so richtig komisch an
falsch ausgedrückt ich weiß eigentlich
dass beschreiben sollen so krass leute
oh mein gott ich habe mich wieder für so
kraft ist in schlechten youtube videos
zu warten
apa red devils neues tattoo an dieser
stelle waren in 40 kilogramm keller fast
so krass wie waren in schlechten
youtube-videos aber nur platz zwei bis
zu real darf natürlich auch nicht fehlen
bei so richtig schön war irgendwie ist
es schon sich entspannt also ich weiß
nicht sind wir ein bisschen anders als
in wasser zu baden
immer wieder würden wir nicht sauber
gerade als youtuber so fühlt man sie
besonders schmutzig waren in 50
kilogramm schicken
also ich dachte mir so ok ich nehme
jetzt ein richtig schönes bad in
schlechten youtube-videos und einmal
diese werte kandidat hier darf natürlich
nicht fehlen und erst recht nicht dieser
klassiker muss man ja mittlerweile schon
sagen von einem video und o2 schon
ziemlich voll hier sind schon so circa
500 kilogramm schlechte gefühl videos
vom teller bader wenn ihr 20 jahre alte
durchsichtige cola trinken weil er das
nicht und cap sieht die nachhallzeit
hält sie nicht sagen warum das andere
klasse und ich sage ich das ist so süß
hier in meinem körper den sie auch schon
ganz schön die schönheit feucht und so
ich bin ein buch und so unvermittelt ein
weiterer klassiker welchen youtuber
gehört dieser art es fühlt sich
inzwischen führte irgendwie besonders
gut an so eine schlechte youtube-videos
daran dass sie da nicht hin tapesh
fotoschau liga pro a herren die
badewanne ist auch schon ziemlich vorne
ist schon richtig krass aber irgendwas
fehlt noch was ist das denn
ganz vieles auf einmal angepackt so
kratz machst mich zu hause da ich werde
mich jetzt mal rein ist so krass einfach
ich also auf das du kannst ja quasi
mädchen in der badewanne voll gleich
geht was wahr ist und was noch 3 2
warum die youtube-videos weggeworfen
worden
das nicht irgendwie papierverschwendung
oder so bei einer trilliarde lights war
ich im auto mgh spaß beiseite wenn ihr
wollt dass ich noch mal mit meinem
bruder zusammen fußball change mache
werde auch diese bilder geschossen auf
diese videos schreibt die kommentare
falls ihr fan von irgendwann von diesen
leuten sei
rege mich nicht um 500 chef bringt mich
nicht um ich meinen körper nur über
schlechten wie das lustige machen nicht
überall - auf einer weil es hätte keiner
verdient